I’m Desmond Wong,
my company is “The Gentlebros”.
We started about 3 years ago.
The game we are working on is called “Cat Quest”,
which is an open world RPG.
After the first bootcamp, coming back 2 months later,
I’ve personally become a better producer.
The mentors have generally helped us
with monetisation methods,
and how else we can make more revenue
out of the game like putting in
in-app purchases or maybe DLCs.
Pricing models, like maybe certain prices
will work better in other places.
Learning from the mistakes they’ve made,
the lessons they could share
was all extremely amazing
Game development is tough,
but keep at it and you are gonna get there someday.
Do not ever give up on your dreams.